police Ryan man University of Technology
always with University of Technology in
Sydney it's going to tell us about some
interesting twists of a lot of the
things we've been seeing this week with
applications to transitions in quite a
bit just out by thanking the organizers
it's been a great workshop and I've
learned a lot this week so everything I
want to say is joined work Michael
Bremner who was also in the University
of Technology Sydney just to motivate
this talk so the main problem in quantum
computing probably the most important
problem is our quantum computers more
powerful than classical computers and I
like to know this to know if I'm wasting
my time on off so there's been like a
lot of success in using methods to an
approximate counting which underlies a
lot of quantum physics as I'll describe
in a few slides time has been recent
success in AI rigorously identifying
complexity transitions in Cisco physics
models it's the topic of most of this
workshop set for example the
independence polynomial in yarn and they
Varna's talk the matching polynomial and
Leslie struck hypergraph colorings in
hangs talk and the Ising model in issue
and Hughes's talk and also I describe in
this talk as well is the fun okay can
like it everyone read this thing four
colors okay anyway so like the main
question is can we apply these
techniques to quantum physics models
which typically are the same as the
testicle physics models once you do some
mapping apart from they have complex
values so they've although so the recent
techniques of Sasha and Patel and whose
have allowed us like an easy way to
study these complex without Eve models
okay
so what does the quantum computer do so
I'll describe this like more detailed in
the next few slides but just to give you
an idea we start with some easy to
prepare state so we're always going to
consider the same state and we'll just
move all the complexity of preparing the
states into the quantum circuit we can
always do this then we apply some
unitary which is a sequence of
my things died I'm sorry
yes then we applied some secrets of
quantum gates so this is a quantum
circuit diagram so we beginning with the
all zero quantum state will then apply
the sequence of H gates which composed
via the tensor product and then we apply
some collection of other gates just in
this case that I can open it generally
they have to be and then we apply some
other atom or gate and this is doing the
quantum computation and then we're going
to just measure and get the outcome so
we get some bit string as an outcome and
that occurs with the probability which
depends on this absolute value of this
inner product squared which will
describe the next slides okay so it's a
quantum state so we're gonna consider
pure States in this there's also
mixtapes but that won't be relevant a
talk to this 12 so it's just the unit
vector in a complex Hilbert space and
then it also has an adjoint which we
write using this notation and this is
just called a bra and this generally
okay so we're gonna use these like
throughout the talk so just remember to
remember this is a vector and this is
the joint and then we can take an inner
product between these so the inner
product just gives you the probability
amplitude for observing some particular
state given like we start in some other
state and then the actual probability of
observing this is just the absolute
value squared okay now how do we compose
quantum states so we've got two quantum
states then the total quantum state of
those two systems is just the tensor
product between the two and then if we
if we've got two state or a state that
we have that has two sub systems and we
can't separate it - we can't composes
the tensor product then we say those
quantum states are entangled
it is an example of a quantum state is
you can try and write as a tensor
product between two states but you
shouldn't be able to okay so we're gonna
consider like an easier representation
called quanta bit so we're just gonna
consider two dimensional systems and
build up from there see the fundamental
object in quantum computing so we write
it like these zero States is just the 1
0 vector and this one is the 0 1 and
these we just call the combination of
basis States and then we just write any
tqex system as like as a linear sum of
these two things and we have the
property that like the absolute value of
alpha squared plus the absolute value of
beta squared just equals 1 because these
correspond to facilities and more
generally we can write any quantum state
in this system as a sum over bit strings
so here we just ignore the tensor
product notation and it's just a tensor
product of each one of these states
individually depending on the bit string
and then the probability of measuring
particular outcome X it's just the
absolute value of this alphas x squared
okay so how do quantum states evolve so
they have obvious and you know to your
presentation
which we call gates so it acts on some
like this okay an su SE UT to the see
they're just like some small constant
see this generally like one or two and
then a quantum circuit is just a
sequence of these gates acting on n
qubits and we say that a set of gates is
universal if it can generate a dense
subset of su 2 to the C so it's C you
can just think of as - in this case it
won't make sense for one and then like
an important theorem by Sol awake and
tired which says the density implies
efficiency so if your gate sets
Universal and condense Li cover su 2 to
the C then we can efficiently get like
close to any point in su 2 to the C just
look like a logarithmic number of gates
and it's sometimes useful to consider
the Hamiltonian picture so so
Hamiltonian is just a self adjoint
operator and if we write e to the minus
i HT then we get a unitary matrix so you
can think of the quantum state evolving
via time so it starts in some particular
state we evolve through this Hamiltonian
percent of time and then we get a new
state at that time ok so now if we
relate this to we can get continuous
time but if you try to build a country
preacher you have to sort of plug in a
real number so it's all my arguments
about whether things are straight or
continuous in my physics so the Hadamard
test allows us to approximate these
particular amplitudes so it gives us
some quantum algorithm where we have one
particular bit and the probability of
measuring it and up for example is given
by this formula
the for measuring down this just gives
the same thing with the minus sign so
the expectation value it's just the real
part of this amplitude and we can repeat
this procedure polynomial number of
times and then we can add to our
approximation with high probability we
can get our approximation that's a one
even poly
and then we can apply a similar thing to
the imaginary part so the main thing is
that just any well provided you this
composed like pulling a many gates then
we have some quantum algorithm which
allows us to approximate any opportunity
okay so how hard is it to approximate a
floatability amplitude so in the exact
case it's gapi hard this is ordinary P
to the gap P and so this is just the sir
the closure of sharp the under
subtraction so anytime I say gap P you
can just think of me saying sharpie hard
so it doesn't really matter the most
important thing is outside the Palio
hierarchy the argument so this diagram
is generally representing like well
complexity classes the more things
you're in is roughly how much easier the
for mr. salt so exactly computing these
amputees is gapi hard and at relative
error
it remains gap be hard up to additive
error its bqp hard so this is the
quantum analog of the Class B key P so
it it's like a decision language so
essentially approximately amplitude
solves all of the problems of quantum
computer can solve well all the decision
problems according to computer can sell
food stereos can we use the complexity
of this exact complexity to bound the
complexity of classical computer
simulated quantum computer so it's not
opening we are factoring inside bqp just
by Sherdog where they're not inside PPP
this like a big open question
okay so now to relate all of this to
approximate counting so I'll create them
by or by Fenna and others says that for
any problem in gap P there's a
polynomial quantum algorithm circuit
such that this probability amplitude
corresponds to the gap P followed under
some normalization so if by the head of
my test that means we can efficiently
approximate any following gap P or any
and also any problem in sharp P up to
some additive error but the problem is
that this additive error is
exponentially large so it's not great
that we don't know it of any classical
algorithm for doing the same thing so
you could make some conjecture saying
there's no classical out of them for
doing this and this is exactly the same
as saying there's a statement like be P
P doesn't equal B P so what well I
think's weird but I guess like some
other people don't is like the nature
can solve really hard problems so you
can have like nature encode these
probabilities of really hard problems
that you can't directly access the leash
you know you can do a sample from it and
try and get an estimate okay so we can
also consider the problem of trying to
sample from some quantum computation so
we ain't least important quotation and
then we're gonna look at the probability
distribution at the end and find sample
from it classically so this is the line
of work by Aaronson arc valve and
blender one error and sheppard and this
is like a general generalization of the
argument so the task is to approximately
sample from some distribution this but
the the quantum circuit has to be like a
randomly chosen quantum circuit but it
still producible in polynomial time you
just want it to be approximately sample
bins close up to some l1 norm so if you
conjecture that this probably is kepi
hard to approximate up to relative our
on average so saying that the worst case
complexity equals the average case
complexity so if you assume this is true
then there's no efficient classical
algorithm for sampling from these
distributions unless the polymer
collapses see you have essentially they
you got a separation between BP p and b
QP assuming the polymeric doesn't
collapse and this can change this tree
yeah say yeah yeah say up to a relative
error so how you ran reaches you depends
on which team you're looking at if for
example based on sampling is that Randy
and linear optical networks you're gonna
give a hint as to what recent progress
means so it's in the exact case so I
think Adam should be here somewhere and
I'm down in Vermont so him and others
exactly have show that in the exact case
with continuous so he needs some
continuous argument that it's hard on
average I think that's right yet to
exactly the view so savor like the
similar sort of distribution in the
exact case
okay so now I'm just gonna divert back
to the Ising model is what we've heard
about that I use like a slightly
different notation so I'm just gonna
give you this ciz mother is described by
some weighted graph and verse these of
the graph can be in two states either
like minus 1 or plus 1 or spin down and
spin up an E and the edges correspond to
interactions between them and vertex
weights characterize external fields
acting on each vertex or each spin and
edge weights characterize the strengths
between interactions between them and
then a configuration of the Ising model
is just an assignment of each spin to
one of two possible States before this
is how we define it it's not escalatory
with more physics way so you guys in
what a petition functions just like a
weighted sum over all of these ball
configurations and the weight is just
given by sums as the edge terms than the
edge X terms and provided all of the
edge type and a greater than 0 we see
them models frenetic Jeff they're all
lessons is there we say an traumatic
now back to some quantum so is it I
don't want to put I keep these circuits
it's an instantaneous quantum poly more
time and I guess the instantaneous comes
from these gates all being diagonal
which not exactly that you could say
that I think I can do these all at the
same time that's not like strictly to
but that's why they call instantaneous
so we can define it by some Hamiltonian
we're gonna defined by some izing
Hamiltonian over some graph so you can
probably guess that that's gonna go that
the Hamiltonian come considers like a
sum over the edge terms given by some
weight and xx terms so yes matrix is
just given by this so it's like a
quantum version of the classical not K
and then we have a son later Versys it
just let some single X game so vertices
in this in this picture correspond to
qubits vertex weights correspond to one
qubit gates and edge weights correspond
to two qubit gates between them so these
to be thought of as entangling gates
similarly if you write this in a circuit
model you get some circuits of the form
you get some I don't my gates and this
just takes the all 0 state and put it
into uniform superposition of all
possible bit strings and then you apply
some diagonal quantum gates and then you
play these hannahmont gates again
okay so what's interesting about the iqp
model the probability average age of
this model are exactly equivalent to
either mode of petition functions with
imaginary weights so now all of the
arguments we had before about quantum
circuits now apply to the ice and water
with imaginary weights and what's the
one thing is that these circuits are
universal in the post election so post
election just means that for some
particular outcomes I can say I
definitely want a zero here and then I'm
going to so usually there'd be some
probability of getting zero on a
particular qubit post election just
saying I'm definitely getting zero on
that qubit and I don't know any other
case so meaning a universal under place
election it would mean that
approximating these amplitudes is as
hard as approximating the amplitude of
any Universal quantum circuit yeah yes
so I guess you'd say with like some
probability depending on how likely the
post-election you want is you would
implement the circuit you want and
otherwise your if it gives you do it for
example if you measure one keep in it
gives you zero you could say okay that
gave me the quantum circuit if I wanted
if I got a one I'd say that didn't I
gave me some other quantum circuit the
fact that I could since you're just
considering the probability of something
you've you're just like forcing this
zero to exist anyway so that's still
corresponds to an izing world of
partition function so you can take any
quantum circuit computation just write
as a position function and even if
you've got some ex gates here you can
just take the ex gates inside and that
just corresponds to something like a PI
over 2 rotation on the field
so they're purely imaginary in this case
and quantum computers can do the able to
compute this right you can't we can't
compete you can get add to her
approximation to this thing we've been
won over Polly or if you get rid of to
TN its to TN everybody you can yeah I
mean it's not great approximation but
it's this is everything at Quantico you
can do into the decision language okay
so especially it's like when can we
approximate this like isin water with
complex like these at any time that we
can approximate it we have a of some
good thing we can approximate the
quantum amplitude
okay so now I'm just gonna motivate
complex values so well I probably don't
need to cover this part but because with
the militias out there so the physical
page renditions are the real limit
points of the complex zeros of the icing
on a pitcher motion this is what Alan
said cool uses justify studying obvious
orders here's our distribution so it
probably updates are proportional
traditional functions of imaginary
weights so implies that nature's
described by these complex values and
models it means and it's also BPP hard
to approximate how to add tavera so
approximating leads to an advert as I
said it's just everything equality can
you can do essentially except for the
sampling thing
ok so now we're going to see what
happens when you apply the sampling
argument to iqp circuits so you're going
to approximately sample from some random
iqp circuit and this is on the complete
graph or a sparse graph where each edge
is phasing with some property law gonna
reverse these or number of qubits over
in a reverse these key bits and then the
weights are choosing chosen from some
discrete set either the PI over 8 and
then from 0 to 7 the T actually is that
if said are the izing want to put you in
touch with these weights whose gap be
hard to approximate up to the level 2
they're on a constant fraction instances
then there's no classical algorithm
sampling from it unless the partner -
collapses so understanding Oobleck
co-running complex sizing models it's
important to separate in quantum and
classical computation this is up to
relative error
okay so how hard is it to approximate
production
so Alistair in Sinclair virtually in 93
gave an F brass for the izing water fish
approach along with permanent take axis
and that's for any field this picture is
going to create me ignore fields as I
there's like quite complicated already
and it's gonna ignore quite a lot result
because the same inning I can't cover
them all
so this diagrams just going to complex
describe the complexity in terms of the
interaction strengths or the maximum of
these so just to go in in your model the
vertex dependent fields right yeah so
they can be very different on different
disease yes these are like randomly
chosen from specie you can make the
argument work for several other random
choices they just chose one that like
this quite natural okay so then so
Allister pshhh and fur Lee gave an FP
TAS somewhere along the and forensic
line up to the point where you get to K
of correlations to sometimes degree
grafts and you're out to the uniqueness
of the gives measure
and then Jing Chen Alistair and pshh
gave an FP toss for some zero free
region surrounding this so they can
apply the buff in a hotline and get an
athlete us up here set shows that this
also corresponds to the region where
zero is condensed
and then Sasha and so Ron gave an F
though is this is the correct notation
quasi-polynomial time approximation
scheme what would you call it it's for
that it's for the graph paper or some
tissue function that you can do like
some reduction to this without fields so
this corresponds to the zero free region
around here there's a note this
corresponds to the quantum line say
along here is everything we care about
in the quantum case that'll induce
extended this to FP TAS and then in this
talk we're gonna extension FPT tasks and
then we're going to include some field
so it's a small field but it's at least
one step towards though
okay then
you can read my text writing right yeah
I can't read myself say ok say sly and
Sun and then independently gallon
Estevan kvitová gator gay partners fruit
for long just outside of this edge for
any regime so this gives like an exact
transition point which things go from
easy to hard and then in a stroke we're
going to do the same thing for the
imaginary access well they were not
actually tight but we're like within
some constant a being tight so this is
for zero field to harvest also I say to
preserve here but I think you should
hope for field as well
I think the constants will just change
them
okay so let's just state the results so
main thing is we get deterministic
polynomial time algorithm for
approximating the conflict palletizing
model on grass of maximum degree Delta
in when these interactions between the
field and the vertex Vesely bounded
close to zero and that's bounded by this
constant which comes from Barbra notes
monograph so yes somebody's here but the
main important thing that this guy
there's like roughly 1/8 of the maxim do
and then we're going to convert this to
quantum to say what this is in the
quantum case and it says we get an
efficient classical algorithm for a
probability amplitudes of to the iqp
form the brass of mass degree Delta when
the interactions of running by to arcsin
this thing you also guys it's like 1/8
for the maximum degree so to convert it
to the physicists on a hexagonal lattice
where we can simulate PI over 23
rotations so you can think of these
fields as just rotations in the quantum
circuit or takings in SU 2 an X you for
a non-square last we can simulate up to
PI over 29 rotations in general like 1
over Delta rotations and this happens
also also or almost optimal cuz we get
hundreds all to him if we allow
rotations up to some constant tools guys
it's 1/8 of the mat-su degree and at
this point it's kept be hard after
approximately Dumpty's at the relative
error and be he'd be hard to
approximately not just mad - there are
these numbers for special innocence of
any importance like would you be
interested - like yep I don't know Phi
over 50 they're like these license we
got so this is like this result was just
for any I guess degree 3 graph really
clear up early just play them yeah would
it be of any interest to to tighten it
or special letters yeah yeah so I think
it's like the several papers that sort
of do this but it's hard to like because
I think you can yeah especially for like
the square lattice in hexagonal you
should there shouldn't be like the worst
case of like to greet for graphs right
so so so square lattice I think behaves
like a graph degree 3 please huh yeah I
could
okay so roughly how does our proof work
I'm not gonna go into this too much
detail as you've probably had enough of
this already but that is we will reduce
it to a pinned graph home office a
mutation function so the petition
function or the brach can walk some
finishing functions to find similar to
analyzing model except when we're gonna
say that sometimes we're gonna not sum
over all configurations we don't allow
some of that configurations to be fixed
and this is going to allow us to
implement some external field by just
adding a burr to adding an edge to every
vertex and then fixing the other spin so
it's a sure and sober on gave a quasi
polling over time for approximating the
graph of motion in production
when these matrix entries will span by 1
over the maximum degree using Viaduct
interpolation or Bartlett's philosophy
and then paddlin who's gathered in
provement following their time and they
had the idea was they expressing the
coefficients is connected in do so graph
house
okay so just just to sketch the proof
look quickly we apply a slight extension
of the paddle and yusup Roche - pinned a
grass so we just the frequency follows
directly we just have to say that we
were like we can now allow us to pin
vertices to particular spins and then I
went about proving like a zero free
region for the pin case but in sessions
monograph actually the proof is by
induction on like pin vertices so I
didn't have to do any work which is
great so this result just gives us
quasi-polynomial time sorry Apollo meet
our approximation scheme for the Ising
model when these weights and we just get
some extra +1 in the max and degree here
from adding north of the vertices
having all the edges every vertex to do
the field
now to sketch our hardness proof say the
problem is that this only works for
multi graphs but I think it should we
should be at extender to number us again
so that the first statement is that it's
gap be hard or be keep yard on graphs is
maximum degree three with imaginary
weight surrounded by PI over two so this
sort of simulates all the rotations you
could do on a quantum computer okay now
we're going to consider the worst case
graph and then we're going to consider
so this is going to be my worst case
graph or some graph it could be the one
you want to simulate we're gonna
consider the cake thickening of this so
the maximum degree of this cake they can
graph just becomes whatever it was
before so example 3 is a hard case and
then times K and now if we allow
rotations up to PI over 2 K on this
graph this these will add together so we
get the exact same PI over 2 thing we
want to look here and then we rewrite
this in terms of K and then we get 3 PI
over 2 Delta so you look see it this
morning the doctor scaling
so this implies gappy hardness of B or B
Pharrell devera and bqp harness to
additive error of approximating the
Ising model partition function when our
weights well they're to be imagined area
bounded by 3 PI over 2 Delta
okay so what are these results imply so
we get some quantum Quebec City
transition roughly that one over the
maximum degree where add to their
approximations transition from P to P Q
P hard and relative error approximations
transition from P to gap P hard so you
can interpret this in the in the physics
model as you could say it's a classical
FP test for some short time evolved
hamiltonians so if we were in imagine T
corresponding to the whites of either
she's thirties and take her zero they
didn't do anything and then as you
increase T we can [ __ ] same time
training and then you get to some point
where you just can't
I also corresponds to quantum circuits
abandoned parents because we know this
altitude can never be zero because that
corresponds to a zero the isin want a
partition function so it's saying what
classes are quantum circuits can we
construct such that the interference can
never completely cancel or go beyond
hassling negative for example and also a
quantum circuits of limited
teleportation so to give you an idea of
teleportation you can imagine having two
qubits entangling them together and then
measuring one qubit and then look at the
effect of you about on the other key
there you can use this to teleport gates
and things so we know we have loads of
teleportation because an ex-gay just
gives you a direct zero so if we could
construct our circuit to teleport things
through and through just to construct
one x gate that we know we could get to
a zero so we know that can't happen and
this also gives a formal relationship
between the geometry of zeros and the
complexity of quantum music
okay so can we apply this to other
probabilities because it seems like if
your system is such that we can compute
one amplitude then we ship here to
compete the other ones so this isn't
obvious and he'll manage to solve this
yet because we require X gates which
correspond to like PI over T rotations
so we can't do those anyway and we know
that just having an X gate on just a one
qubit thing just gives us a zero and
this means the icing on top addition
function zero but maybe we could use
decay of correlations to get around
under this and maybe have some argument
which works regardless of what the field
is so I guess you could just say like
even if we just had like a completely
several system of several qubits and PI
X gates on them there's no correlations
that somehow this algorithm won't work
okay so you haven't problems in this so
we'd like to identify an exact quantity
transition point so we know in the real
case like the ideal model we know an
exact transition point we'd like to be
able to do the same along the imaginary
axis we'd also like to experimentally or
because if we probe the transition point
is we expect at some point there's got
to be some physical properties of the
system that means that it's easy to see
mates go to heart to make the
entanglement dynamics go from short
range to long range or the some
interesting physics there and then also
we'd like to extend these arguments to
other probabilities or sampling problems
maybe using like things like decay of
correlations methods and we'd also like
to apply these techniques to many body
physics so in the case where the
Hamiltonian doesn't commute this isn't
even we ever had much success doing this
way and also to understand the
relationship to other methods so money
chain Monte Carlo the calculations and
then other methods from quantum which we
can now compare to so the tensor network
methods and stabilize a rank method or
just describe where these are in a
second
the thing is like people expect to you
who work on these so they can't see me
like this system using like their
techniques so stabilizer rank in like a
common toriel thing you have see the
theorem of EI governing in welsh says
that the top polynomial is hard upon
them like eight special points and they
correspond like some some of them
correspond to like on the either model
partition function and then we're gonna
say what quantum circuits see few days
so that gives you discrete subset of su
is like two to the n called the clifford
group we can efficiently compute any of
these probabilities so the stabilizer
rank says we can take like any like say
none stabilizer or something that's not
easy to compute and we can write it as a
sum and generally this inherits
exponential complexity is you're
decomposing every gate like twice but in
certain circumstances you can say okay I
can like do this and I need after do a
lot of
okay so in this in the workshop program
it mentions connection to the local EMA
so I'm gonna have it have a go at that
so maybe I'll just like skip this part
so the logical mo says that we have some
sequence of events and the Fogler of
each probability occurring less than P
and each to event event depends on most
Delta other events so provide the P is
bounded by this thing explodes like
roughly 1 over Delta then the
probability none of the events occurring
is greater than 0 so this is useful in
existence proves it forgot some
collection of random graphs for example
and we know that this the probably of
something you're carrying is none zero
than we know there's a graph of that
property ok so can we take this into a
quantum - local EMA
so there's already - they're coming
there's completely different flavor so
in our scheme we're gonna say an event
it's just measuring the outcome one on
qubit K and then the dependence is just
the maximum to be at the graph and then
provided we have these things on the
weights so you can imagine doing the
vertex weights first and that gives you
the probability before you do your
quantum circuit of each thing then the
probability of getting the all 0 state
is greater than 0 or you could say the
probability of no events are carrying is
greater than 0 so it gives you a polymer
like when can you decide if interference
cancels out like an event so this is
np-hard in general I think maybe sharpie
hard ok so maybe we could try and find
an application of this so this is like
quite far off but maybe what's the
existence in quantum physics me say for
example maybe in quantum field theory
you can map the probability of getting
some particular particle to a transition
poverty in the quantum computational
model and then provided it satisfies
these certain things that we know
there's like a nonzero probability of
detecting a certain particle so maybe
there could be some experiment where you
want to say can I get this particle out
of the experiment and that happens with
like something like one over a thousand
for ability or something you'd never see
it but provided the your experiment
satisfies this then you could say ok
there's like a nonzero probability
hey Sango have that
[Applause]
question
so using quantum computer so real that's
what do you mean by real yes so for
example for example that Shor's
algorithm will be implemented to factor
numbers with several hundred digits well
I'm just gonna guess so I actually oh I
don't think anyone knows the answer I'd
say yes I'm not quite optimistic because
I think there's like several things in
physics where someone will describe some
principle but yeah okay that works a bit
like you know we had to build it and
then they end up doing it like it's
really hard to predict our technology
advances
so how how would you respond to that
argument that you need such a precision
of quantum circuits that physics laws
basically don't pull to that precision
well I mean you can you can build small
scale ones and I still the problem is
like an engineering challenge and like I
guess like 200 years ago if I said like
I could build like this can't this
laptop then like I think people wouldn't
believe me then you say well I don't
know the answer but I can't article the
nineteen thirties or something where
somebody was proposing rocket propelled
to a new position and there's a material
or something we said I think professor
so-and-so seems to be unaware of the
knowledge that is later in our daily in
high schools and forty years later they
forbidden in atoms so the only thing is
only for I could be but if you allow
everything that you get all of these so
I say it's a chest pocket paper but
since you're any approximately amputated
it's for all of ATP
if you imagine other complex then you
can map some quantum circuit but I'm not
sure it'll be universal okay see you can
take any model from like the furniture
so you could do a like an antibiotic
Ising model and then you know the exact
transition point but the problem is when
you do this as your quantum circuits got
some weird structure to it to implement
this like an traumatic thing that you
want so you could say okay I know the
complexity transition of this quantum
circuit but it's like very unnatural
okay well I've got something workshop
said I think Ryan emails so everybody
for contributing to nice